so hi everyone
work I continuum analytics working on
blaze odo
a couple of other open-source libraries
as well as doing a little bit of
consulting so first I'm going to sort of
give a quick overview of blaze and how
that works and then I'm going to sort of
jump into a problem where I'm going to
figure out which which New York City
boroughs you want to avoid because the
taxi drivers drive too fast all right
alright so I'm going to start with a
quick poll who uses like raw numpy just
like based on pie okay so that's like
most people loses pandas like okay also
most people cool so blazes sort of
design around the interfaces of both
these things and designed to to handle
systems that don't fit into the
abstractions that numpy and pandas
provide so it's a it's like a
lightweight lightweight interface on top
of like things that already exists so if
you have a database blaze can work with
that if you have a data frame blaze can
work with that if you've a CSV file
blaze can work with that it's a couple
of imports you see this in the back is
big enough they're so okay is that
better okay bigger eventually things are
going to start doing that and get cut
off later but all sort of adjust as I go
we can also sort of operate on on sort
of like objects that have a table like
structure so if you have a list of
tuples we can work with that and the way
roughly speaking the way blaze works is
that you you create a symbol that's an
expression and then you build up an
expression tree as you go and we'll go
through some examples of that and they
let you build up they let you write code
that feels sort of like numpy and pandas
but can run code on sort of a system can
can execute code against your data where
it lives rather than having to bring it
somewhere do your stuff and then send it
back so let's start with something
something really simple lists right we
can give blaze a list and it's sort of
happily lets you do kind of computations
with it
I forgot to actually run the notebook
can't see any output
okay except that work maybe no sorry
ok
ah until I don't don't really use the
slides feature that often all right
there we go please use pandas for pretty
printing because has anyone ever looked
at the pandas printing code oh I'm sorry
it's fun okay all right so right so we
can sort of write these expressions do
whatever we want with them and it sort
of feels like standard kind of numpy and
pandas and we can we can operate on so
the thing the thing I was showing you
here is just like basically a vector
it's a symbol list and then but we can
can operate on a list of lists or so if
anything that looks like a table this
little thing that showing you the time
is a little ipython extension that I
wrote that lets it's called Auto time
and anything anytime you run anything it
will just spit up time that it took to
run okay and so we can do we can do
aggregations you do sort of column
access and there's the the underlying
thing that's driving sort of the
operations and describing the data
layout is something called data shape
which is a type system that combines the
shape of your particular piece of data
so in this case I have five rows and
then I have a sort of struct like thing
which we call a record with these fields
and with these particular types so
here's X again this is what it looks
like everything kind of looks like
pandas because of course we use their
printing let's say we want to know who
has a negative balance the deadbeats so
you can you can sort of do it as if you
were we were operating like with pandas
directly this may not seem that
interesting is like okay why don't I
just use pandas where it becomes
interesting is when you when you start
generating like more complicated like
sequel queries
they'd have lots of filtering and
joining and so forth and I'll show a
couple of examples of that in my in the
taxi trip data set exploration so that
was driving a list of lists this we can
sort of just drive pandas as well and
our code basically looks exactly the
same it's getting cut off so I'm doing
the same exact thing that I was doing
before with the list of lists the
outputs of every blaze operation are
blaze expressions so if we look at the
type of deadbeats it's a field and the
reason is because I'm saying dot name
right here it's a field access if you
look at the child of that expression
it's a selection which is a filter but
if you actually want to get out
something concrete you call compute okay
so i say compute on deadbeats and that
runs the expression against whatever
back end is bound to the data object
bigger sure good
so we've got the type of the result of
compute yeah type of that is a panda's
series so in general when you input
something from a particular ecosystem
like a panda's thing or a pure python
thing or a sequel alchemy thing you're
going to get back a thing from that same
ecosystem so I input a pandas dataframe
I get a series out I input a numpy
record a I get a numpy array out we can
work with various other things like I've
already mentioned Python in pandas we
can also work with sequel alchemy tables
so here I'm constructing a table that's
not really bound it's not bound to a
database it's just a table with a name
and a couple of columns and their types
so i can say i can i can look at the
data shave i can look at the table and
again we follow this sort of principle
that you get a fit you get a thing of
like type x in and you're going to get a
thing of type x out so here you would
your when you call compute on on
something that's bound to seek welcome
you think you get back a select object
and you know because those things have
some nice printing mechanism built in
you can actually look at the sequel
that's generated you know modulo the the
bound parameters but you can also look
at those two will see that later so
let's actually connect to something real
here I'm connecting to a the iris a
database equal I'd database that's
holding the iris data set one thing
that's nice about blaze is that it
allows you to sort of explore structures
that don't that aren't necessarily
tabular so for example here I'm actually
I've made a data object of the entire
database so I can sort of drill down and
look at tables and explore what's there
with their data shape and I don't have
to so if you were to do this with sequel
alchemy right you would have to sort of
you would have to create a metadata
you have to stick the engine in there
you'd have to look at all the tables and
then you would have to sort of discover
all the types plays does all that stuff
for you which makes it a lot easier to
inspect your data so the the fields of
the database are tables and then I can
sort of just like I should before we
just have an extra like sort of level in
the expression tree that has all the
tables and we can do more more
interesting things like group by here
we're groovin by the species and getting
the min and Max sepal length for each
species and of course we can look at
that by calling print on the result of
compute and there's an underlying
library that plays uses to describe how
to access data and that's with these
URIs and that's part of odo which I'll
talk a little bit about later so that's
that's sort of the that's sort of the
intro the ended the intros anyone have
any questions so far yeah
do all that equation all the stuff in
memory with 10
in the database
it's like
right so the example that I really
wanted to show but I didn't I ended up
using a different database because I
didn't want to depend on the Wi-Fi is
like driving a redshift instance with
this stuff which is you know where
wherever it is and I can I can interact
with the remote thing as if it were here
on my on my machine which is kind of
nice because I don't have to think I
don't really have to think about like
sending the sequel over like getting the
result back as like whatever it is
parsing it I just sort of say hey like
Siegel alchemy like send this query over
and then that the underlying sort of DB
API handles handles that stuff for me so
interacting with things are where they
are rather than bringing them to you is
the is the main idea here yeah not at
all execute
yeah yeah so you could get back a result
from the database that just won't fit in
memory but there's a few ways you can
get around that we have like there's
some streaming stuff that's sort of in
the works at the moment but yeah the
wherever if you're using if using a
sequel database it's going to execute in
that sequel database natively it won't
ever bring things into memory then do
your relational algebra any other
questions yeah
I'm sure there are I can't think of any
off the top of my head 11 sort of thing
that we're discussing talking about is
if we want to go down the route of going
like it deep down in a particular back
end and sort of saying like hey like
this back end isn't going to give you
what you want but there's these other
back ends that have various sort of for
example like time series operations and
in in databases are fairly hard to
express uniformly across all of them
like for example like generating listed
numbers in my sequel is like really hard
there's no as various like ways and
things that they don't implement that'll
don't allow you to to do that kind of
thing where you could you maybe want to
like generate a date range and implement
resample or something like that and you
know postgres has like a generate
sequence function but like you know you
can't even generate a list of numbers in
my school so those kinds of problems
make it difficult to to even go like in
11 back end and sort of abstract
everything away so it sort of depends
any other questions cool let's do
something a little bit more interesting
okay so this is a notebook that I wrote
for strata last whenever it was recently
and originally I was like what borough
has the fastest taxi drivers I just
thought it would be funnier if we just
called that which borough should we
avoid so first I just define a couple of
things this this like piece equal thing
is like will actually like take the take
a seat block we query like compile it
stick in the the bind the bound
parameters stringify it and then pass it
to sequel parse which will like format
it in a kind of nice way otherwise like
see clock me just kind of spits like
single like solid rose sequel at you
which is hard to like show anyone and
make them think it's cool so i'm i'm
going to using like their bunch of
different libraries and even more as the
sort of thing goes on so i have i have
like the New York City Taxi trip
datasets sitting in Postgres a local
postgres instance any kind of looks like
this all rights dalian hack license
vendor blah blah blah passenger count
trip time in seconds and so forth so the
first thing i want to do was actually
like get rid of trips that are outside
of New York City because I don't really
care about Connecticut or New Jersey or
wherever the heck else like taxis can go
I don't think they can go outside the
tri-state area but there there are in
fact like some points that are just like
you know in Vermont or whatever so the
sort of went to this this website and
they have a nice little polygon here the
outlines new york city for you and at
the bottom it shows you the minimum
maximum latitude longitude so I took
those I said I only want a trips that
are within this box and I only want
trips that are less than the distance
less they're equal to the distance
between the
the corners of the box so postgres has
some operators like this I don't even
know what to call this like left arrow
at sign right arrow but basically what
it does is it does like a spherical
point-to-point distance between these
two points so that's kind of fun so this
is the maximum distance that I want to
laugh there are any trips that are
longer than 39 miles I'm throwing them
out so you can use this equality pretty
straightforward blaze has displays sort
of like doesn't get in the way if
there's a thing the for example like
blazes have any point data structure or
like whatever this operator is so
sometimes you need to get down into the
thing that the blaze is talking to
because it doesn't give you like full
access to the to the thing so we get
this out now we have our floating point
then we filter out a bunch of like
crappy data example there are trip
distances that are negative there are
trip distances that are just like huge
like thousands of miles there are trip
times that are like zero as well as
negative their passenger counts that are
like 255 there are like their passenger
count like I there's also like a
significant amount of passenger counts
that are like nine like I their taxis
that can hold nine people even a van
anyway so and then and then this these
this sort of filter right here is is I'm
not using the whole polygon but i'm
making a box out of new york city and so
that this is using blaze and you kind of
you can kind of see that it looks like
pandas but this is executing against
postgres and so this is the sequel query
that that's actually being run
alright so there isn't a way there isn't
a column that already exists in there
isn't a column that already exists in
the table that has like the trip time an
hour's good i want to calculate miles
per hour so i make that and the way you
do that is with the function blaze
called transform which i'm going to sort
of move down here so you guys can see
right so so i write the thing I ballad
or is this filter that I have above and
then this filtered data set i compute a
column i say trip time seconds cohorts
or to a flirt flow to turn it in two
hours and then i take valid you know
that the trip distance and / hours in
miles per hour and then I can kind of
just inspect it like that and this is
sending a sequel query in like slapping
like limit 5 on the end and then
bringing back those five things so we
only bring back as much data as it needs
to show the first 10 rows unless you
convert it to something else and then we
can see for example like how many trips
have a have a mile an average speed in
miles per hour that is like greater than
120 miles per hour that's pretty fast so
it's like 20,000 trips in there but
heaven where people were just I don't
know what was going on there but there's
actually some trips in there to have
like that are approaching like 90,000
miles an hour
so this there's something strange going
on it's possible that some of the like
latitude/longitude that the distant or
that the that the speed is taking sort
of into account latitude and longitude
that have like zero values in them
because there are those so I also don't
care about trips that are like you know
moving at a snail's pace so on a filter
those guys out and I'm going to project
some columns out right I'm going to take
out the thing that I just computed I'm
going to get the pick up pick up
latitude longitude and drop off latitude
and longitude these are the things I
ultimately care about to sort of to do
to do my sort of final file analysis so
at this point to figure out like which
boroughs I need which boroughs contain
like which data which taxi trips I need
to like consultant external API because
that data is not in the original data
set so I'm gonna use odo and a bunch of
other things to get that out but first
let's this is our dis is the data that i
just created with the filter and the
projection and this is like the sort of
sequel query that's being run so you
luckily don't ever have to like look at
this stuff unless you want to so how do
we get borough geolocation data turns
out the city of New York has a pretty
nice API that gives you back this XML
format called KML that gives you
geometries for particular for all the
bros that kind of looks like this yay
XML not so i'm going to use something
even worse than XML that's called xpath
I'm sure there's an XPath wizards in
here
I am NOT one of them and so there's
place marks are like the nodes and the
XML tree that mark the burrows so I
created some code that no one should
ever look at to parse and sort of clean
this stuff up basically what i'm getting
are a string that sort of looks like a
csv file so it's got the longitude the
latitude and the bro name let's sort of
inspect our day with pandas make sure
things like don't look ridiculous so
they don't and let's like really make
sure that things don't look ridiculous
okay so this is using bouquet and just
wanted to draw the borough's make sure
that things aren't totally out of
control and that the data i'm getting
and that I'm what I'm doing with it look
sane sure yeah so so it lets you kind of
you pass in a data frame you give it x
and y that our column names and then if
you give it color it will cycle through
colors and plot the the individual
groups by a particular color this code
right below it is something that I just
discovered like 30 minutes ago because
the the points were gigantic and sort of
filling in the entire borough and looked
weird I'm sure there's a better way to
do this but I don't know bouquet that
well so I was really happy to find that
the scatter plot was like really trivial
to write once I sort of had my data all
right so odo is a thing that will let
you turn a thing and do another thing so
in this case I have DF as a data frame
I'm turning into the temporary CSC and
then shoving that into a Postgres
database now you might think oh that's
like really shitty and inefficient but
the loader is actually generating sequel
code specific the database that uses the
native loader for the CSV so it doesn't
actually doesn't like send it to a CSV
and then like use pandas like read CSV
turn it into like you know a list of you
know turn into like a list of
dictionaries send that the database
which is going to you know have to do
its thing writing to the database and so
forth that's going to be terribly
terribly slow this is actually probably
the fastest loader and Python and sort
of cheating though right we're like
taking the CSV and saying oh like what
do we know about the CSV generate the
the sequel code for it but as user
you're totally insulated for it so that
was really fast right I was like 30 like
37,000 rose is not a lot of data but I'm
sure if you did that in pandas with like
two sequel it would probably be 10x slow
or maybe I don't know and for really big
things it's it's really bad like like it
took like 17 hours to to write the
entire like New York City Taxi trip
dataset from its CSV into a database and
like 20 minutes if i use otoe so 20
minutes for 17 hours pretty good this is
what it looks like as we sort of know so
now I have to dive down in a sequel
alchemy because i want to start using
some more primitive geometric objects
like boxes points and line segments so
what I just sort of did this bounds
right here this is saying group by the
borough and give me the maximum and
minimum latitude longitude and make a
table out of it well it's actually
making a select select statement but
that doesn't really matter to work as we
clock me with my blaze thing all i have
to do is call compute on that right and
then i make an alias because i'm going
to need to join them and i need to keep
track of the names this is sort of the
key point that allows me to do what I
want to do with
with this whole thing basically what I'm
doing is I'm joining on whether a
particular trips line segment was inside
of the box of a burro the horse or
problems with doing it this way but I
tested I tried to do it post gross as a
polygon type which I tried to doing it
but it was it was much much too slow so
I have some ideas about I get around
that but I couldn't get to them for this
talk right so then I'm going to need to
select out the things that I want which
are the bounding box named the borough
name and then all these columns that I
had before but I'm going to do a group
by I'm going to average the speed /
borough and count the number of samples
because i want to see if like you know
maybe like Queens has a lot fewer cab
rides in Manhattan it does and finally
this is the like final sort of sequel
query with all this stuff Jerry so I do
the filter then i compute my column that
has you know trip trip speed average
speed then I joined that thing with the
bounding box group by take the average
and get up those columns at the end and
odo lets you take this whole query that
I just built up and just like say boom
turn it into a data frame who's going to
take a little bit not that long like 20
seconds yeah
so the a base gets me like the geometric
stuff which I like because I was able to
think about it at a higher level than
saying oh like let me create these
filters that like are a box rather than
just saying like hey puss puss like do
you think so the end result is this but
not really it's either out that it's not
that much faster right it's like 17 and
I'm this is not like rigorous in any way
statistically so yeah and and of course
like there's 80 I only have 83 like stat
on cab rides definitely nothing in
Staten Island go fast right right right
right and also they're like I have a big
like to do list here various things but
ok so that was the end result the point
is like you can kind of like Python and
blaze and see clock me and all these
things kind of just let you let you
serve go hog-wild an answer like
ridiculous questions probably useful
ones too so the yeah go ahead that's
really hard you couldn't calculate it
sort of the polygon bounds yeah
what if i do have a right so in no but
yeah so so there is PL Python I've never
looked into that but yeah that's worth
looking into in that particular example
I actually was doing that about an hour
ago but it was just so dog slow that I
because you're checking like there's
like 37,000 points versus like four
points for a box so I was also the way
you have to do it is also kind of
annoying because the polygon like type
constructor only accepts like a list of
strings so I had to like take my
latitude longitude like turn them all on
the strings then construct the polygon
then check if the points are so it was
like way way less efficient so that can
be you could probably get around that
fairly easy bite down sampling the
polygon because it's totally there's so
like 37,000 points is like totally
unnecessary for this analysis right i
mean like maybe it's you need that for
drawing a map but you don't need that
for this thing so the glaring sore a
problem with the box approach is that
you have like areas where Brooklyn
Queens Manhattan all overlap so you're
going to get wrong answers for certain
for think for whenever a trip is like in
you know Queens and in Brooklyn it may
say it's like in the same borough
I'm not doing anything more
sophisticated with like traffic speeds
or dates like holidays may be more busy
this is also five percent of the entire
data set if i was able if I was less you
know dubious of the Wi-Fi here I would
have used red shift and that thing can
handle the whole data set in like a talk
in like an amount of time that I could
give in a talk yeah that's it any
questions yeah I don't know let's go
that way good meaning like if I have a
database from over here nothing uh right
now that stuff only works with in-memory
data sets and it will it will bring like
stuff in memory do the joint and then
give you back essentially a data frame
so you can't that doesn't work for
things that don't fit in memory yeah you
you could definitely do that for sure
yeah how about objects turns the other
one right so if I try to run this thing
again it would upend to the there's no
updates be like we don't have anything
that does updates but that good that
could totally be a thing that just needs
someone to sort of motivate the use case
there's definitely a use case but once
you get a day your frame from the Select
45 dating Frank this
yeah once you turn it into a data frame
yeah so you could yeah you can
definitely like convert it to a data
frame and if you want to do something
else and insert back in you can just say
odo this thing to the database depending
on where that thing is going going to
and coming from that's going to be the
performance is going to vary wildly so
yeah not sequel zevi said yeah yeah if
it's tabular it's not very difficult
there's yeah so there's there's a couple
of things you have to do like you have
to implement an odo API which is like
three functions and then you have to
implement like as many expressions as
you want to work which is I know they're
probably about like 15 to 20 expressions
so yeah there are some other questions
hands yeah
I probably can't give you a number and
the second answer is I don't know
probably not because we couple of things
we're like hey like we don't really like
this API of pandas so we're not going to
we're going to use something else so
we're going to use something that's
closer to like a declarative syntax
that's closer to sequel like distinct
and so it's sort of it's a little bike
shedding but it's totally legitimate
question because people ask that all the
time and it just it usually depends on
like how much magic the particular
pandas API implements if it's
straightforward like we could probably
do it if it's like group buys that may
mutate state on the grouper and also on
the thing that they're grouping on like
it's that kind of stuff is pretty much
out of scope because everything in blaze
is immutable yeah
bhushan wasn't just like a foul
right so compute says we can get into
details maybe afterward but basically
what it is is it it walks the expression
tree bottom-up evaluating each
expression turning that into a new leaf
and then then recursively about doing
the same thing until it finally reaches
a thing where there's only one thing in
the scope until it finally reaches a
state where there's only one thing in
scope and then it returns that's sort of
the very high level overview any other
questions yeah in certain backends we do
like column pruning but we don't do
anything like push downs or yeah we
don't we don't do a lot of optimization
we could but yeah we just haven't we
haven't had to implement the time
implement that yet so any any other
questions cool how much time do I have
go ahead more time I'm not going to talk
anymore I'm just wondering where yeah
so you would have to add a few types to
data shape but once you did that you
have had a few types of day shape and
then tell oh doh like hey here's how to
deal with these types here's how to like
say what data shape do they turn into
right so if I I don't know that they
have like a polygon do they have a comp
some kind of polygons yeah so any of
those geometric objects that you wanted
would have to be like describable in in
both directions so I've need to be able
to say this is a data shape what does it
turn into and post just and here's a
post just thing how do I describe it in
Datia [ __ ] once you did that you yeah
you'd probably be able to there may be
other things but yeah yeah
around
so just wondering
what would you say like
like any causes people
our reliable
so I personally have worked fairly
heavily on the sequel back end so that's
the thing that I know the most and that
thing has seen the most work out of all
the back ends so it also has like the
most coverage of the API that it uses
because it's using sequel alchemy and so
sort of using see cockney SuperX
extendable and so it allows like us to
take advantage of whatever they have and
like for example I started working on a
recent poll expression and like
surprisingly i was able to get it to
work with like sequel it--and postgres
via like various things and it's kind of
built in layers we're like you know you
anyway like I would say that the sequel
back end is fairly reliable and that the
[ __ ] back end is not something that you
should use not necessarily because well
it is kind of collecting dust a bit but
you just shouldn't it's kind of a
corollary of not using [ __ ]
I think we have a graphic somewhere on
the well I'm going to use the graphic
anyway because I'm don't remember what
they all are
back ends okay that's invisible oops I
want to turn at the moment all right
that's not very useful so I would say
sequel pandas pie spark depending on pie
spark like that we have the spark back
end actually what it does is it takes
your blaze expression translates into
sequel and then turns it into a compiled
string and then runs like whatever the
spark contexts whatever dots equal thing
it does and that's what we do so blaze
has this way that lets you sort of pipe
to other back ends if there's like an
easier way to do that so I would say
this i think it's using sequel is going
to be pretty reliable pandas is good
spark pi tails and b calls are kind of
be calls because like there's various
issues that we run into it at some times
and pi tables because i don't know i
don't think anyone's using that i'm not
using it but it could be interesting so
yeah they're all sort of in various
stages of maturity it kinda depends on
what users are what our users are using
and so since wheeze we have users that
are doing a lot of sequel that is where
a lot of our efforts are focused cool so
thanks guys
you